bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans file echo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les grandes
lignes de cette émission les yvelines
font partie de la cosmetic valley un
cluster rassemblant près de 800
entreprises de la filière beauté et
c'est donc à versailles que s'est tenu
le congrès olfaction et perspectives il
présentait les nouveaux champs
d'application de cette branche
d'activité
il s'appelle axel courson et maria gaffe
n'est leur point commun ils changent de
vie professionnelle pour se lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat il veut créer une
brasserie locale elle reprendre une
crêperie le dossier de la semaine
dévoilera ses deux portraits la chambre
de métiers de l'artisanat organisé ce
lundi son premier forum de
l'accessibilité un moyen pour les
commerçants de se renseigner sur les
démarches à effectuer 40 2015 leurs
locaux devront tous être accessibles aux
personnes handicapées et avec nos
invités nous discuterons justement de
cette obligation sur notre plateau
thierry leur président de la capeb lille
lyne bon soir et lilian cannes bonsoir
directeurs associés de aq si omar un
cabinet de conseil en accessibilité
absolument donc à tout à l'heure avant
d'entamer ce débat on passe à
l'actualité économique de la semaine et
on commence donc avec ce reportage sur
ce premier forum de l'accessibilité des
images d'elodie moines
des élévateurs des rentes des bandes de
guidage pour personnes malvoyantes
nous voici au premier forum de
l'accessibilité yvelinois car d'ici le
1er janvier 2015 espaces publics
transports et cadre bâti devront être
accessibles aux personnes handicapées
pour les fournisseurs de matériel du
secteur cette loi multiplie les
opportunités oui cette année
de vente que les années passées et ça ça
devrait revenir en notre faveur pour
l'année prochaine encore pour ce
commerçant l'enjeu est tout autre il
connaît bien les problèmes
d'accessibilité son frère est en
fauteuil roulant mais il regrette le
manque d'accompagnement on essaie de
l'entrepôt de la démarche savoir les
subventions je pense qu'on est très très
mal informée à ce niveau là parce
qu'aujourd'hui
noah qui vient qui nous ait pondu on dit
voilà il faut réglementer on se soucie
pas de savoir si on a le budget ou pas
ça c'est la première chose qu'on sait
pas si on l'avait vu subventions pas
pour conseiller ses commerçants la
chambre de métiers et de l'artisanat a
réuni également des avocats des
conseillers financiers et les chambres
consulaires selon elle a les subventions
existent bel et bien mais reste limitée
il ya des aides effectivement qui existe
on sent du territoire et les fisac il ya
des filles qui m'a aussi local via le
parc naturel régional il ya une aide qui
devrait arriver très prochainement et
maintenant du conseil régional pour
effectivement les commerçants artisans
est ce que répertoire des métiers mais
ça reste effectivement que des coups de
pouce que des aides ponctuelles la
charge financière incombera donc
majoritairement aux commerçants la
chambre de métiers de l'artisanat
devrait organiser régulièrement des
journées d'information sur le sujet
la cosmetic valley organisée aujourd'hui
avec la chambre de commerce et l'école
isipca le congrès olfaction et
perspectives utilisez les odeurs dans le
domaine de la santé du marketing ou
encore de l'environnement c'est possible
explications avec ce reportage réalisé
par don avec jonathan littman les
métiers liés aux odeurs ne se limite pas
à la parfumerie c'est le message que
souhaitez faire passer les organisateurs
du congrès olfaction et perspectives qui
se tenait ce jeudi à la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie c'est aussi
surtout de parler des nouveaux champs
d'application de l'olfaction passe comme
on l'a dit c'est un sens qui était pas
mal oublié jusqu'à aujourd'hui alors
qu'en fait c'est un sens qui va nous
permettre finalement de pouvoir ouvrir
de nouveau métier une grande ouverture
en tout cas pour nos jeunes aussi non
seulement dans les métiers classiques de
parfumerie de la cosmétique ou dans
l'alimentaire mais aussi on l'a vu dans
le domaine médical on verra dans le
domaine de l'environnement parmi les
avancées présentées la détection de
maladies par les odeurs ou encore le
lien entre émotion et odeurs appliquée
aux biens de consommation sont veut
positionner un produit comme étant
relaxant une crème hydratante comme
étant relaxante on pourrait aussi
proposer un parfum qui aille dans ce
sens là émotionnellement pour renforcer
et suggéré d'autant plus ce pouvoir par
exemple relaxant de la crème c'est un
peu ça l'idée donc finalement pour nous
en tant que fabricant de parfums et
d'arômes sait sélectionner nos produits
en fonction de certains positionnements
émotionnel finaux des biens de
consommation et des produits de
consommation les yvelines représente un
territoire clé de ce secteur 500
entreprises de cosmétiques y sont
implantées ainsi que l'école isipca
créée en 1970 par jean paul guerlain
lui-même la région ile de france fait
également partie de la cosmetic valley
avec les régions normandie et centre
d'abord un impact d'attractivité zik
dans le monde n'y a rien de mieux donc
c'est un peu une silicon valley dans
lesquels encres est en fait un mouvement
qui a choisi à la fois la recherche la
formation les pme la cosmetic valley
représente 18 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires et prévoit 1500 création
d'emplois d'ici 2015 la plupart d'entre
vous ont déjà sur mon reçu leur taxe
d'habitation et leurs taxes foncières
dans les villes de plus de 10 mille
habitants chaque foyer devra débourser
en moyenne 682 euros mais les écarts
peuvent être importants attrape la taxe
d'habitation est de 376 euros contre 788
à bois d'arcy et c'est la ville du
vésinet qui bat des records avec un
montant de 1000 322 euros dans tous les
cas vous avez jusqu'au 15 novembre pour
payer
37 jours que les syndicalistes sud de
psa poissy font une grève de la faim
devant les bureaux de la direction du
groupe mercredi matin l'un d'entre eux a
dû être hospitalisé outre une
dégradation des conditions de travail
dénonce à un harcèlement syndicale la
direction de peugeot leur a proposé de
réintégrer leur poste ou d'accepter un
plan de départs volontaires eux
réclament d'abord du changement et des
dédommagements
un traceur pour lutter contre le vol
c'est ce que propose la société
britannique smart water à vélizy auchan
a décidé de mettre en place ce système
afin de sécuriser sa bijouterie une
présentation été réalisée ce matin le
principe est simple en cas d'intrusion
un brumisateur se déclenche et aspergent
les potentiels voleurs dans liquide
invisibles à l'oeil mais comportant un
code unique une sorte d' adn qui permet
d'identifier l'auteur et le lieu du
délit le système est encore peu présent
en france mais déjà en angleterre les
services de police et de gendarmerie
devrait être équipé d'un lecteur dédié
yolaine thorez a interviewé le directeur
français de smart water il revient sur
le succès de ce procédé on l'écouterait
alors le système smart water existe
depuis 2003 en angleterre la
commercialisation date de 2003 en
angleterre mais le produit existe depuis
1996 depuis ces dix ans de commerciaux
en bleu terre les résultats sont 90% de
dresde a taclé là où on est présent en
france on a 25 mois d'installation et
commercialisation et on est en
dissuasion sur le territoire et puis
avec un résultat qui correspond au
résultat anglais c'est à dire que la
dissuasion prime est vraiment nos
clients le prenne pour ça vraiment pour
assurer leur personnel et aussi pour la
tranquillité des clients qui viennent
tous les jours et qui peuvent se
retrouver face à un braquage et on
protège des centres commerciaux des
bijouteries des buralistes des sites des
entrepôts sensible des casinos e on a
vraiment des cibles différentes mais qui
ont toutes la même problématique c'est
qu'ils sont en risque d'être attaqué
aussi bien aux braquages cambriolages
alors où faut-il ou fait-il bon vivre en
ile de france pour y répondre le site
changer de ville point com a réalisé un
classement basé sur onze critères
transport sécurité ou encore coût de la
vie et c'est versailles qui arrive en
tête ses mauvaises notes en termes de
logement par exemple sont compensées par
son offre culturelle et son
environnement
on vous annonçait dernièrement le
lancement de l' y box un coffret
permettant d'obtenir 50% de réduction
sur une offre de loisirs dans le
département un nouveau guide va bientôt
lui sert de la concurrence le groupe
passtime spécialisé dans les coffrets
implante une nouvelle franchise et dans
les yvelines elle devrait lancer son
coffret versailles et ses environs au
printemps prochain avec des réductions
dans les commerces les restaurants et
les établissements de loisirs du secteur
et c'est maintenant l'heure de
l'entretien
ce soir nous allons discuter
accessibilité d'ici 2015 les locaux
commerciaux notamment mais aussi les
espaces publics et les transports
devront obligatoirement être accessibles
aux handicapés pour les commerçants
quelles règles à suivre qui finance le
délai est il tenable nous inviter vont
nous aider à vous nous aider à y
répondre par don sur notre plateau nous
recevons lilian khan directeur associé
de taxi home donc un cabinet de conseil
en accessibilité et thierry lorho qui
est donc le président de la capeb
yvelines nous pressent dit qu'à des
artisans du bâtiment alors les
commerçants sont souvent peu perdue face
à cette nouvelle réglementation de
l'union ken votre métier cette facilité
un petit peu leur tâche finalement au
fait est ce que c'est si compliqué que
ça alors pour nous c'est de moins en
moins l'idée justement c'est
d'accompagner nos clients qui
effectivement sont plutôt des
commerçants des patrons d'établissements
qui sont en recherche de mise en
accessibilité de leurs établissements et
donc on va les accompagner sur toute la
chaîne depuis la phase de diagnostic
pour identifier quels sont les points à
améliorer en termes de d'accueil de
personnes à mobilité réduite ainsi que
toute la partie assistance à maîtrise
d'ouvragé pilotage suivi des travaux de
manière à ce que le jour où la
commission d'accessibilité va se
présenter à leur établissement de puisse
avoir ce fameux le label qui leur
permettra d'accueillir le plus grand
nombre de citoyens en général quand ils
viennent vers vous c'est parce que ils
ont peur de faire les mauvaises des
marchés ne savent pas vers qui se
tourner alors on règle générale ils
viennent me voir la faire nous pour
trois raisons la première c'est l'aspect
réglementaire bien maîtrisé la
réglementation et savoir quels sont les
points à améliorer dans leur
établissement ça c'est la première des
choses s'assurer qu'ils seront en
conformité avec la législation le
deuxième point c'est que c'est un un
environnement dans lequel il y à des
données techniques produits qu'ils ne
maîtrisent pas forcément dont qui nous
accompagnait qui nous viennent nous
solliciter également pour ces sujets là
et enfin dernier point c'est les aider à
ce que les travaux se passe de la
meilleure façon possible
pour leurs projets justement concernant
les travaux un label a été créé pour
être sûr que les installations soit aux
normes c'est ce que propose la capeb
avec handibat nous c'est un label qui a
été je pense créé en 2004 avant la loi
finalement gardé de quoi s'agit-il la
capeb était très en avance d'immenses
sur le sur la loi donc depuis 2004 on
propose à nos artisans des formations
d'une part pour appréhender les
problèmes de réglementation parce
qu'elle est très stricte
c'est la partie très importante
pour leur montrer effectivement qu' il
n'y a pas d'eau on peut pas jouer avec
ça tout ce qui a été étudiée prévu dans
la réglementation à cet argent mon
parcours c'est tout à fait la petite
marche qui pour une personne valide de 5
cm est insignifiante pour les personnes
à mobilité réduite ça devient un
véritable obstacle donc on les met en
situation pour qu'ils se rendent compte
ça peut devenir un obstacle la maîtrise
effectivement des aides qui les
personnes peuvent avoir trait
particulier voilà pour les particuliers
principalement voilà de façon
asymétrique non en totalité le sujet et
auquel ils sont pas toujours habitué
dans leur principal de leur clientèle et
qui puisse apporter à la personne
demandeurs le meilleur service et
surtout le meilleur confort
appel à des entreprises la plupart du
temps les travaux sont identiques pour
l'artisan c'est la même chose
posez une porte ou chambon s'il faut la
changer effectivement ça va avoir un
coût mais un interrupteur le met à 50 cm
de hauteur ou 70 cm ça change rien le le
priva très rarement est impacté par le
fait que ça soit
destiné à une personne à mobilité
réduite ou un chantier traditionnel un
appel aux artisans du secteur c'est
ouvert à tous s'attendre à tout à fait
adhérentes i appel ou non c'est une
formation qui est ouvert à tous verte à
tous les tous les artisans
et tous les artisans sont concernés par
la mobilité réduite c'est pas seulement
des problèmes mécaniques
le peintre peut être aussi concernés par
des gens qui ont des difficultés
visuelles
l'électricien pour les gens c'est une
perte d'audition
donc tous les artisans responsables
alors au delà des artisans vous même
vous êtes confirmé puisque vous avez
obtenu ce label c'est un peu particulier
vous n'êtes pas du tout dans l'artisanat
c'est important pour vous donc c'était
même essentiel la logique c'était de se
dire on voulait absolument se
positionner sur l'accessibilité et il
nous fallait absolument avoir un label
qui puisse dire voilà nous sommes
experts nous maîtrisons toute la chaîne
et pouvoir le prouver et il ya les
réflexions qu'on a porté sur comment ce
comment apporter cette valeur ajoutée
nous ont tourné vers le label handibat
ce qui nous a intéressés c'est vraiment
cette philosophie de prendre
l'accessibilité au coeur de toutes les
réflexions et notamment sur la notion de
qualité d' usage au delà de la
réglementation qui elle est très précise
et donc il n'y a qu'à la respecter en la
nuit quand strictement mais également
d'avoir une logique de qualité d' usage
et d'aller un petit peu plus loin que la
réglementation et de se se dire voilà je
me mets en situation ça c'est ce que
nous apporter vraiment le label handi
alors lors du forum nous avons rencontré
le jardin c'est en coiffure de
sartrouville vous avez même s'ils ont pu
lui parler lundi donc lui a ouvert son
enseigne en janvier 2012 les problèmes
d'accessibilité il connaît ça puisque
son frère est en fauteuil roulant mais
face à cette réglementation il est un
peu un peu perdu je vous propose
d'écouter son discours
quand on vous dit demain il faut
magasins soient accessibles je veux bien
qu'on soit qu'on fasse le minimum il
arrive un moment il faut nous donner les
moyens aussi c'est pas dire voilà et il
faut que votre commerce soit accessible
mais vous vous débrouillez quoi donc là
on est un peu dans le flou des petits
gens comme nous qui viennent d'ouvrir un
commerce c'est pas évident sachant qu'on
on n'est pas confronté
depuis des années à ce problème là on le
vit depuis quelques années mais
mais on n'a pas assez de recul par
rapport à ça
même si on a un handicap chez nous
je pense pas qu'il soit en mesure lui
même de nous dire voilà pour accéder
dans ton salon il faut que je puisse
faire ceci ou qu'il faudrait que tu
faire cela donc il donne son point de
vue
son extérieur avec son handicap à lui
mais on n'a pas notre monde un prix
modique à
des difficultés à trouver les bons les
bonnes installations et puis ces
problèmes de financement
finalement quel z il peut y avoir un
lien cannes alors aujourd'hui pour les
on va distinguer deux types de
financement premier saut avec le
financement ni aux particuliers
puisqu'on est dans une logique de
handicap ça va voilà ça peut toucher
tout le monde
donc là on a différents financements
mais le sujet qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui pour les commerçants on est
plutôt sur des financements de type
fisac peuvent être allouées
auprès des commerçants qui en feront la
demande tout se mélange et ça reste
quand même assez réduit finalement quels
sont les autres contraintes
souvent des contraintes techniques
principalement dans les commerces des
petites surfaces et donc des grosses
difficultés à créer des surfaces
suffisamment importantes pour pouvoir
manoeuvrer se déplacer créer une rampe
s'il ya une marche pour entrer dans un
commerce et vous peut-être des problèmes
parfois prenait des problèmes de voirie
puisque avoir installé un dispositif
de dispositifs qui existent
effectivement
se déploie souvent peuvent se déployer
sur la voie publique mais
sur la corde je vous propose de
rejoindre bernard longatte ce qui est en
ligne
bonjour alors vous avez une double
casquette vous êtes représentant de
l'association des paralysés de france
dans les yvelines mais également membre
de la commission d'accessibilité
départementale alors est-ce qu'on a une
idée un petit peu de la situation dans
département est ce que les yvelines sont
un bon élève
n'est pas le plus mauvais département
c'est pas non plus le meilleur
atout très 20% des commerces qui sont
pour l'instant règle c'est ça alors là
je vous répondrais oui j'achète un on
n'a pas de données de google c était là
présent nous avons d'avoir l'ailé les
gens nous voyons en commission et un peu
pour la wii est-ce que selon vous
finalement l'échéance de 2015 est
réalisable escroc un peu attention sera
associé reconnu également il ya une une
réunion qui se tient en permanence entre
le gouvernement va les représente dans
la démarche reposant du gouvernement les
associations
visant à définir les les conditions d'un
moratoire
pour finir on a très peu de temps mais
pour vous le problème principal ce
serait quoi c'est le manque
d'implication le problème de financement
le problème c'est vous et bien
évidemment les codes amis qui a vendu un
bien sûr
actuellement dans la conjoncture
actuelle ne fait qu'aggraver la
situation
la plupart du temps les gens n'ont pas
les financiers
conséquents à ferreira alors je sais pas
ce serait surtout cela je vous remercie
beaucoup bernard hamon gâte merci
d'avoir été avec avec nous sur ce
plateau je vous remercie également à
tous les deux merci à vous et on passe
tout de suite au dossier de la semaine
pour ce dossier nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de deux créateurs d'entreprise
maria gaffney aient accès à la cour sont
donc l'ins lui ne se lance pas redondant
une reprise de crêperie et l'autre dans
la création d'une brasserie locale nous
les suivrons tout au long de leurs
projets donc durant plusieurs mois ce
premier volet revient du coup sûr le
début de leurs deux sur leur lancement
on va dire il est à réaliser avec elodie
moines
maria a racheté cette crêperie de
guyancourt il ya une semaine à 44 ans
une nouvelle vie démarre pour elle celle
d'entrepreneur
et a pris l'affiché avec amour a séduit
en courtoise vit avec ses trois enfants
à quelques pas de là depuis son projet
de reprise elle a transformé sa cuisine
en laboratoire culinaire et pourtant
rien dans son parcours professionnel ne
la destinée à confectionner des petits
plats il y a encore quelques années
maria fait carrière dans une grande
société informatique
j'étais responsable marketing europe en
longtemps pendant pas mal d'années
après
après le décès de mon mari je savais que
ça allait changer les choses allaient
forcément changé mes enfants étaient en
bas âge et
donc j'ai mis le temps un petit peu
avant de pas tout changer en même temps
j'ai mis un peu de temps et après ça
j'ai démissionné de mon poste pendant
quelques mois maria se cherche d'abord
consultante puis professeur d'anglais un
jour elle passe devant cette crêperie en
vente c'est le déclic elle postule avec
succès à une formation de créateur
d'entreprise à la chambre de métiers de
l'artisanat celle-ci se clôture demain
elle doit présenter son projet et bien
évidemment ces crêpes j'espère que le
jury va mais je ne suis pas un cordon
bleu évidemment mais je veux juste
montrer le concept en fait de ce que
c'est qu'une et aux crêpes riant femmes
dans cette néo crêperie se mêleront aux
crêpes traditionnel des lasagnes des
maquis et des gâteaux tous à base de
crème bien sûr cette chef d'entreprise
délèguera leur confection un chef
crêpier qu'on le restaurant ouvrira au
delà du concept maria à repenser tout le
magasin nouveau nom l'envi devient la
crêperie du village nouveau logo et
nouvel amménagement deux mois et demi de
travaux sont prévus elle reste à trouver
une partie du financement des banquiers
feront partie du jury demain peut être
une piste
à ixelles a suivi la même formation que
maria cet été son projet tout autre il
souhaite lancer sa brasserie ingénieur
de formation il travaillait jusqu'en mai
dernier dans l'audit financier là c'est
une passion fait la brasserie du coup je
brasse depuis 2012 et commencer ici
c'est chez moi avec une petite des
brasseries
le qu'on peut se procurer sur internet
et voilà j'avais cette passion j'ai
profité d'un moment de flottement
flottement professionnels pour pour me
lancer dans ce projet concrétisé cette
passion l'a transformé en métaux axel a
commencé avec ce simple quitte une
marmite un sceau du houblon et du mal et
avec tout ça on peut faire de la bière
notamment je fais ma bien l'un sans qu
une bière qui se veut local de par son
nom cinq eu pour saint quentin en
yvelines mais aussi ses matières
premières
maltais houblon sont produits par des
agriculteurs des environs et pour avoir
la bière parfaite il a fallu tester
différentes recettes ses gestes sont
toujours en cours après moi je recherche
pour pour faire une bière bombe une
bière qui est quand même une identité
mais mais qui ne soit pas trop forte
c'est parce qu'en même rafraîchissante
donc s'arrête une bien je pense qu'il va
tirer sur des sur des notes un peu un
peu végétales pour amener un côté très
et j'essaye aussi de faire une peu andré
hunebelle en bray qui elle va avoir un
peu plus de corps plus de caractère et
qui voire peut-être dénote un petit peu
caramélisé on verra ça à développer les
essais que je fais vont donner un petit
peu les grandes lignes quale les grands
caractères de la bière mais toutefois je
peux pas obtenir une qualité de bière
pas aussi élevé que si j'avais le
matériel professionnel d'ici la fin de
l'année il devrait recevoir ce matériel
professionnel le savoir faire il a
appris cet été lors d'une formation dans
une brasserie de douai dans le nord pour
l'instant il doit se contenter de
peaufiner sa recette dans sa cuisine
mais bientôt il s'installera dans ce
local
pour être chaussées à 140 mètres carrés
vous qu'il va me permettre de faire une
zone de production une zone de stockage
et de garde chaude et un espace
dégustation pour pouvoir recevoir le
public faire de la vente directe et
aussi donc organiser des visites les
visiteurs pourront découvrir la
fabrication de cette bière artisanale
mais en attendant l'heure de la
présentation du projet a sonné
actuellement blessé au bras c'est maria
qui l'accompagnent à la chambre des
métiers de l'artisanat axel se lance
dans sa présentation son projet son
business plan et pour finir une
dégustation le jury a l'air plutôt
emballé le projet en lui-même l'idée
l'idée est bonne après je pense que
l'acteur
est averti aussi c'est un enfant de 50
ans donc il a toutes les clés en main
pour pouvoir distribuer sont produits au
travers des canons qui connaît et voilà
je pense que saint quentin est porteur
de pas mal de consommateurs déjà de
bière le fait que ça soit une bière
locale c'est apporter un gros plus c'est
ouais moi j'y crois des banquiers
qu'avec
sûr et qu'on allait se voir après pour
en discuter donc c'est vraiment de
confort
c'est maintenant au tour de mariah un
peu stressée elle vend son projet
l'ouverture est prévue début décembre
mais pour le jury finir les travaux à
temps et recruter un chef ray pied un
serveur dans ces délais semblent
compliquées vient l'heure de déguster et
pour maria de souffrir le jury bien
sanglé
positif quelquefois négative des fois
j'ai eu peur des fois aussi et que
diacre auch pas ils n'adhèrent pas au
projet du tout qui se trouve ça trop -
en fait la draperie traditionnelle qui a
maintenant qu'ils ont dégusté ça change
un peu la donne apparemment m'avoir 6-1
suis mais
je contente très très très content parce
que montrer aux autres enfin tu es assez
professionnel la donne de larmes la
crédibilité avant projet évidemment mais
aussi l'entrée dans la réalité et c'est
la réalité que le nom prochaine étape
pour maria et axel présenter leur projet
devant des commissions d'être
financières et des banques pour les deux
nouveaux entrepreneurs
l' aventure ne fait que commencer
et nous les suivrons donc dans la
poursuite de leurs aventures au fil des
mois à venir et c'est maintenant l'heure
de l'agenda
il vous reste une semaine pour vous
inscrire au concours créarif quartier il
est ouvert à tous ceux qui auraient un
projet de création d'entreprise et qui
habitent dans une commune
d'ile-de-france qui présente des
quartiers prioritaires comme une zone
urbaine sensible par exemple a gagné un
accompagnement au premier lieu mais
aussi des formations des parrainages ou
encore une mission exploratoire au
québec c'est la fin de ce fil est qu
merci de nous avoir suivis je vous donne
rendez vous jeudi prochain bonne soirée